but of course we're going to begin with
the hurricane Ian I know you've heard
all about it strengthened overnight to a
category 3 storm as it barrels towards
Florida and barrels is a word you can
see it in this video how people are
already fleeing the state on packed
highways they're just trying to get away
from the danger and here's why take a
look at the huge size of the storm as
seen from the International Space
Station that is huge the hurricane is
expected to strengthen to a category
four before making landfall as soon as
tomorrow possibly in Tampa which hasn't
seen a storm this size in more than a
century Omar via Franca is in Clearwater
Florida which could take a direct hit
Omar good morning to you I heard
officials there this morning saying
everybody take this seriously get out
and people are doing that good morning
Gail people here on the West Coast of
Florida are buckling up the Port of
Tampa is close to incoming traffic
Tampa's airport will shut down later on
this afternoon evacuation orders are in
place for hundreds of thousands of
people on Florida's West Coast as
officials say that Ian will affect the
entire state
hurricane Ian has landed in Western Cuba
but its outer bands have already lashed
the island with heavy winds and rain
yesterday in the coastal Municipality of
batabano Crews with the Red Cross and
the mayor work to evacuate at-risk
residents to Higher Ground
we're going house to house she said
taking out the elderly and children
in Florida some people are boarding up
their businesses and homes ahead of
Ian's arrival the demand for plywood
emptied shelves in some places we just
want to make sure we get at least some
coverage since we weren't expected to
come right at us and now it looks like
it is we will see on the Gulf Coast of
Florida heavy rains strong winds flash
flooding storm surge as Governor Ron
DeSantis warned that all Floridians
could be affected by Ian the rush to
stock up on other coveted Goods like
non-perishable food and bottled water
created massive lines at grocery stores
some gas stations were depleted of fuel
in Tampa people waited for hours in
their cars to pick up sandbags
and here in Clearwater we met Gabriel
alley as he loaded up with sandbags of
his own people are helping each other
out hey you need bags hey let me give
you a hand oh it's been kind of bringing
people together actually
some hospitals in the area are closing
and transferring their patients to
safety even NASA is not going to take
any chances they moved the Artemis
rocket indoors we should start seeing
some first signs of Ian here in the next
24 hours Nate
Omar thank you